Conway CEO of Goya Foods
Bob you know I didn't see this one
coming it's
it's really the same as Bud light's
transcan or targets tuck it in I mean
you've if you look at the website for
Chick-fil-A they talk still talk about
honoring God there that that is the
pursuit their mission statement
um How do you
is this the same
well first of all you know we just had
Memorial Day passes and I thank you for
your service and for our freedom to this
country we're a generation that has only
known freedom and I like the analogy of
the guy that built uh Dubai who said his
grandfather wrote a camel Etc said
strong people Hard Times create strong
people strong people create easy times
easy times create weak and soft people
and soft people create hard times and if
we don't get our act together we're
going to be riding camels and pulling
rickshaws uh pretty soon as far as the
boycotts go uh I have an easy solution
they should have come to me first
because all you got to do is bring in
AOC and have her a boycott your company
and art sales when she did that to us
she was eating her own uh our sales went
through the roof but but seriously uh
and we made her honorary employee of the
year for boosting ourselves
for for donating four and a half million
pounds of food working with the with the
Obamas working with President Trump and
saying we were blessed I used the word
blessed and that pissed everybody off
but more importantly this isn't about
boycotts as Kurt Schilling said and God
bless his son and Semper Fi
as Kurt said you know we are in a war
what I'm saying is we are in a war of
good versus evil good versus wokeness
greed pride pride is a sin Indulgence is
a sin I've seen the the video on the
systems of Perpetual Indulgence it's
horrific
it's a war against the credential
culture a war against the family against
a child we are exploiting abusing our
children and there's no age limit when
you don't respect life in the womb
you're not going to respect it out of
the womb there is no line it's not a
blurred line they've taken away the line
we're not respecting life how do these
corporations avoid this Bob is it do you
have to have a mission statement that's
Ironclad you know is it a board of
directors thing like how does this stuff
sneak in how do you our arms all these
big companies are run by investment
funds the black rocks one of the biggest
investors in Target is Blackrock they
have their agenda they're not firing
their president Laura Ingram almost
three years ago asked me if I was going
to apologize I said hell no
you know you will apologize and then
you're fired you got to have cojones all
right I will translate that later you
have to have cojones you have to have
courage and they're run by these
corporate funds these investment funds
that have no agenda except to bring in
wokeness with another word for communism
they don't give a crap about the people
you know they don't they're setting the
agenda it's not the companies and you
know it's the board who is put in by
these woke uh peop investment companies
boards and get you know uh they're
killing our 401ks they're destroying it
you know if we are going down and I'm I
you know Latino also uh we come from
countries where they're destroying the
company moving away from God we've got
to move toward God and we gotta
absolutely uh
save you know we got to move towards
salvation culture
amen amen uh and cultures are difficult
to protect you've done that at Goya and
you've you've uh you've not backed down
Bob thank you so much hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else